good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1762 object
class neutralized previously safe
special containment procedures SCP 1762
one is held in a standard containment
unit at site during the periods when SCP
1762 one releases SCP 1762 two video
logs are to be recorded for future
research
although instances of scp-1730 nain
mantilla 'not description SCP 1762 one
is a plain cardboard box that is 32 by
20 by 26 centimeters
it is spray-painted silver on the
interior and exterior and the words here
be dragons are handwritten in black
permanent marker on the lid of the
container opening the lid of SCP 1762
one when it is not in the process of a
release reveals it to be empty SCP 1762
one will infrequently open and initiate
a release of SCP 1762 two during this
time the box will briefly emit a large
amount of black smoke that quickly
dissipates it takes an average of 20
seconds for SCP 1760 to - to emerge
after the smoke cleaners SCP 1760 to -
is the collective term applied to the
beings that emerge from scp-777 teen 60
- to bear resemblance to various types
of dragons in both eastern and western
depictions
albeit in similar forms to that of
origami models analysis of SCP 1762 to
reveals that they are composed of commie
paper after exiting SCP 1762 one
instances of scp-1730 in length from
nine to 30 centimeters and are capable
of sustained flight once they exit a CP
1762 one and have been recorded
attaining speeds of 15 km/h the number
of SCP 1762 - varies with each opening
of SCP 1760 to 1 with numbers ranging
from 50 to over 400 after approximately
two to three hours of time spent outside
of a CP 1760 to 1 all instances of
[Music]
scp-1730 P 1760 to 1 will once again
begin emitting smoke and instances of
scp-1730 P 1760 to 1 SCP 1760 to 1
closes once all SCP 1762 to have
returned to it the next date of release
is inconsistent
a message written or carved into a
varying material will sometimes
materialize on top of SCP 1762 ones lid
once the Box retrieves all instances of
scp-1732 to have provided negative
results these documents and their
appropriate dates of appearance are
being compiled and recorded addendum
1762 one on 2,000 SCP 1762 one began to
undergo a series of events that lasted
11 months and 28 days these events as
well as prior incidents that led up to
the beginning of the scenario have now
been classified under the title the
Jabberwocky event
addendum 1762 o to documentation of the
Jabberwocky event document 1762 one date
obtained 2004 this is the first recorded
instance of scp-713 you have found us
thank you it has been so long since we
last saw each other friends the peace
has been upheld the Giants and the he
must have kept their word and to have
not caused any trouble since you last
came and gave the order we missed your
company how was your family been do you
still know how to work your room you are
welcome to visit anytime document 1762
for
they'd obtained 2004 it's strange to see
how much your world has changed it is
even stranger to see how we appear in
this place in fantasy we are much bigger
or maybe you have growing taller fantasy
is still the same we hope you can visit
us like you used to
though our room is as grand as ever it
appears yours as shrunken we do not
understand the rooms were supposed to be
maintained as it was our agreement
please restore the belief document 1762
six date obtained 2005 only twenty
instances of scp-1730 P 1762 one friends
we apologize for our few dollars we have
had to remain in fantasy for quite some
time
the others are growing impatient we are
trying to keep the peace but please for
all of our happiness repair the room
quickly we know you are trying your
family is the most imaginative of us all
documents 1762 14 they'd obtained 2015
along with ten instances of scp-1730
balls of yellow crumpled construction
paper were expelled from a CP 1762 one
these pieces were observed to shake
violently for five seconds then ceased
all further movement they were picked up
by a CP 1762 - and returned to SCP 1762
one Giants were foolish your room was
not ready to accept them yet we're sorry
friends we hope that we can still see
you but time is growing short for our
happiness document 1762 15 they'd
obtained two thousand five instances of
scp-1730 they immediately returned to
SCP 1762 one after depositing it on the
floor tensions are rising fantasy is
becoming darker we the serpents and the
hybrids are furiously trying to hold
them back but the Giants and else wish
to strike and make an entrance they say
that your family has grown stupid and
ignorant
we hope this untrue
it would sadden us all greatly to know
that you have forgot
documents 1762 16 data obtained mm a
single read instance of scp-1730 1762
one its wings were torn and it was
noticeably crumpled it collapsed onto
the floor one minute later and did not
move again upon its expiration the body
of SCP 1762 to rapidly unfolded and
revealed a message written on the white
side of the paper or goodbye friends
two hours later as CP 1762 one opened
and emitted flames that reached two
meters in height and temperatures of
over 1700 degrees Celsius sounds of
distant roaring were heard from within
[Music]
scp-747 people's were ejected from SCP
1762 one several damaged SCP 1762 two
were also expelled and were deemed
deceased upon examination SCP 1762 one
continued to sporadically open and close
for the next six weeks during this time
it continued to emit fire as the amount
of paper discharged from it steadily
decreased matter resembling muscle and
tissue was continuously expelled from a
CP 1762 one at increasing frequency SCP
1762 one remained closed and inactive
for the next seven months document 1760
217
they'd obtained mm this document was
discovered lying inside the interior of
SCP 1762 one it was written on parchment
and many of the words had been blurred
or stained with blood are you still out
there
friends we miss you dearly fantasy is no
longer safe our Haven your beautiful
creation is gone the Giants are dead
the centaurs are dead the birds have
fled we are going to bury your room we
cannot risk hurting you this is our
goodbye maybe one day your family can
build another room this is maybe a
hollow hope but we will cherish this
thought one hour later ASCP 1762 one
began to shake and emit smoke for 15
minutes after which ship began to sag
and collapse several portions of the Box
began to char and tear creating small
burn holes throughout the words here be
dragons on the lid of the box were
burned away documents 1762 18 date
obtained mm this is the final message
obtained from SCP 1762 one it was
written in ink on a papyrus scroll and
also depicted a scene of a painted
mountainous landscape filled with large
trees and waterfalls a single winged
dragon can be seen in the background it
appears to be flying away
the message is written in black ink in
the bottom right hand corner
master says that we won't see you again
we are sad so are the remaining others
we once filled each other's heads dreams
and goals it's so sad that we cannot
share them any longer Master says we
have to go he says that he will make us
a new fantasy
he says you cannot be part of it we are
sad we love you we will not forget you
we are scared will you forget us upon
removal of documents 1762 18 salt water
began to leak from SCP 1760 to 1 and the
burn marks that covered the container
began to disappear three minutes later
as CP 1762 one had been restored to its
original state the words here be dragons
were replaced with the words here were
dragons
the Jabberwocky event is declared
concluded with this occurrence addendum
three since the end of the Jabberwocky
event SCP 1762 one has shown no further
anomalous properties and has been
declared neutralized SCP 1762 one and
three deceased instances of scp-1732 two
now reside in researcher Yoshihiro
Takahashi's office or commemorative
purposes
addendum 1760 to form update December
31st 2015 after nearly eight years of
inactivity researcher taka naka reported
SCP 1762 one began emitting purple smoke
and spontaneously opened at 2300 hours
falling to the floor it dislodged a
single chunk of crystal later identified
as amethyst and a large leather-bound
book the contents of this book appeared
to detail various specimens that once
lived within the world of SCP 1762 two
though from what the author has written
all organisms mentioned are likely
extinct this book is now classified as
SCP 1762 Bol one the amethyst crystal
had the following words carved into it
one last time
after falling has CP 1762 one
continuously emitted smoke for the next
40 minutes before ceasing all activity
upon trying to pick up a CP 1762 one
taka naka reported that the Box
proceeded to disintegrate upon touching
it its remains are now kept in a
containment capsule in his office so
turns out I actually have the book right
here I'm guessing you all want to know
what's inside it
now this book is classified as CP 1762
bol one well bol is an acronym for
beasts of the old letters let's explore
it shall we
you hold in your hands the paper keys
the keys that can unlock fantasy
when I first discovered this wonderous
land I could scarcely believe everything
before me the spiraling and floating
mountains that reached so high that the
rings of clouds are still below them the
great waterfalls that sprayed down from
the ancient rivers that flowed through
forests with trees wise and full of
knowledge the oceans with their golden
beaches and cool lapping waves that
never roared nor stormed and the life
within such unique and wonderful
creatures that walk through this
fantastic world it took years for me to
gaze upon them all who knows I may have
had more to see I can't see them anymore
though the land is now barren and cold
so empty and sad that even the icy Ridge
that lines the northern forests would
offer more warmth
everything is vanished all the wonder
gone all the vibrant and amazing things
this world once had to offer disappeared
I still wonder where they went I doubt I
will ever know all I do know is that I
have my books my stories and the
memories that are already beginning to
fade away as I grow aged and alone in an
old man's mind that still believes a
long last fantasy may return I don't
think I'll live to see them come back
but I'll heed these stories to whomever
finds them so that they can know that
they did exist
beasts of the old letters Aleph fox when
dawn shines through the trees of the
soft needle forest you can find the alla
Fox humming through the giant lilies for
a morning meal a beautiful two-headed
bird slightly larger than a full-grown
man with downy rainbow feathers that
quiver ever so slightly as they run
through the warm morning breeze the alla
Fox has four wings that are more akin to
an insect in a birds but they blend
seamlessly with the back of the creature
they are jeweled and delicate and they
catch the early rays in such a way that
they glint and shimmer the alle foxes
heads each sport a single large crest
which changes color from one bird to the
next their eyes are round and a deep
purple their beaks gold and slender and
their cries the cry of an alle fox is
sublime a smooth crisp and echoing
warble the heads take turns as they call
out one rising one falling one rising
one falling alle fox eggs are pure white
until the chick comes close to hatching
during which they will turn vibrant
shades of pink green blue and gold the
chick is no larger than a hand and like
any other infant bird naked and blind
for a few weeks the first coat of down
is white as well but as it grows older
colors will show through layer upon
layer until a full array of hues coats
the bird I had the great privilege of
seeing an Aleph ochs nest myself after
many years of exploring the soft needle
forests before I had to rely on the
records and drawings from the Dragons
they are built on the ground nearly as
wide as a dinner table interlaced with
the branches of the thorny ivy to keep
predators away from the chicks the
interior is matted with Tufts from down
the berry bushes indeed the berries
themselves are brought back to feed the
young - of course I could only marvel a
few precious minutes before the parents
returned and proceeded to fiercely chase
me away for a good quarter of a mile
before they returned back to their eggs
nonetheless I felt a great deal of
happiness knowing I had witnessed such a
rare sight with my own eyes
bump goals and enigmatic and dare I say
frightening creature the bump goal is
the Dragons themselves say they do not
know how or when the bumpkins arrived in
the Black Rock forests to the north but
they have lurked within those rugged
trees for centuries now I dared not to
travel into the Black Rock forests alone
that place crawls with the animals of
the night and is a place of mystery and
fear the good wizard Garin and the
dragon Darwin's accompanied me all the
way I am forever grateful for their
willingness and courage as the Black
Rock Forest loomed nearer I began to
remember tales of bump go encounters
some poor brave soul who went exploring
alone when the ashen trail was not yet
made what dreadful and terrifying
experiences they must have been half a
mile into the trees and the sunlight was
already almost completely blocked out we
relied on the soft glow of the carpet
moss and ringed mushrooms the mosquitoes
were vicious to the wizard and I another
15 minutes of walking and we saw our
first bump go or to put it more
accurately bump goals five of them all
hunched over as they crooned over a
carcass from the dim glow of plant life
I could see the muzzle of what may have
been a waddle grunt all of us halted
afraid to disturb the creatures easily
30 even 40 feet tall a single clawed
bird-like foot and leg that rose all the
way without any other limb or torso
until it connected with the head
a giant rounded thing covered in thick
matted down there two enormous eyes that
Shon like moon
casting light onto the dead waddle grunt
and illuminating the dead creature more
than I would care to see they say the
eyes of a bumpkin hypnotized and put the
unfortunate gazer into a state of shock
and terror had we not immediately frozen
they may have turned to us as well aybe
uncle has two mouths one giant seemed
hidden beneath its hairy head filled
with thin needle-like teeth the other is
underneath its foot the toes acting as
teeth that clamp and fastened onto flesh
as the inner ring of jaws greedily bites
off bits of flesh the sound that the
bumpkins were making was atrocious we
stood there silently for the next half
hour by the time the bumpkins began
retreating back into the dark the waddle
grunt was unrecognizable a pile of
cracked bones and entrails The Dropper
flies began falling from the branches of
the trees above to pick at the few
remains
we followed the ashen trail back into
the clear where a flood of relief
greeted us I would not return to the
Blackrock forest again for years
charm changers more akin to a spirit at
an animal charm changers nonetheless
have a special place in the fantastic
lands and so I have included them in
this book with their intense curiosity
and near limitless variety charm
changers can be found in any place so
long as magic exists there in their base
form they resemble wisps of pink yellow
and orange light sometimes looking like
a human child sometimes no more than an
amorphous blob with two round eyes they
are very pure beings and have an intense
attraction towards materials used in
spell casting with a particular regard
for books and Scrolls as such charm
changers have been revered as guardians
of magic shops libraries and rune spots
alike visitors and creators of such
places would be wise to leave a small
offering of some sort to the charm
changers usually consisting of a story a
carving or a rune stone charm changers
will take such offerings and turn them
into a vessel for themselves thereby
adding the offerings magical power to
its own and providing itself better
protection for an otherwise delicate
body those who keep charm changers happy
are blessed with prosperity once
appeased charm changers are more than
happy to assist those who visit or work
in the place they inhabit however charm
changers can be corrupted with offerings
of dark subject matter as well as being
forgotten or neglected charm changers
that suffer such treatment will become
cursed changers and turn otherwise
benevolent places into areas of ill
fortune and disease cursed changers are
black green and silver as opposed to
their lighter counterparts and once
transformed are impossible to change
back the most tragic incident of charm
changers turned curse
occurred at the library of not where an
offering of contaminated elixirs turned
nearly 200 charm changers into maddened
spirits that began to leak poison into
the streets the dragons were forced to
burn down the entire library
incinerating the charm changers along
with hundreds of scripts and books
drop-off dwellers at the edges of the
Coral flats and bountiful cliffs where
the seaside takes a plunge into cooler
waters pods of drop-off dwellers float
and Bob lazily in a peaceful slumber
they are shaped like a teardrop that
grew immensely swollen on one side with
a small pointed tail that does little in
terms of moving its enormous body
dwellers rely more on the current to
move than themselves going for months at
a time without food until drifting back
to the fantastic lands easily up to 80
feet long there are two distinct species
of dwellers the dwellers of the Coral
flats possess distinct growths on their
heads which are actually coral colonies
that have fallen and become a fixed
during feeding times coral dwellers are
a light blue color with lighter rings
dotting their backs cliff dwellers are a
muddled brown with much more numerous
blue spots their tails end in a clump of
streamer like skin flaps that ripple and
twirl as the dweller moves slowly
through the waters dwellers come to the
fantastic lands once a year corals
during the spring and cliffs in the fall
at the Coral flats dozens of dwellers
lined side by side at the drop-offs edge
where together they inhale huge amounts
of seawater sucking down the old dead
and leftover remains that accumulated
over the winter when they are done
feeding on the debris the reefs are once
again new and ready to begin a new cycle
of life
on the bountiful cliffs dwellers spit
out water high into the air at the fruit
trees above freeing hundreds of heavy
trees from their burden and into their
mouths life below also rely on the
falling fruit for a final feast before
winter comes when they either must go on
a long journey to warm waters or wait it
out in hibernation regardless of which
season drop-off dwellers play a key role
in making sure the coasts of the
fantastic lands stay vibrant the eschol
berg forest while not as large or dense
as the soft needle or black rock forests
the escal berg forest and it's singing
groves are a popular destination for
commoners and explorers alike despite
its name the escal berg forest is not
actually a forest and is instead a
single large organism each of the trees
in the forest as a runner sent up by a
large and complex root system which is
impeded in s Goldberg peak the trunks of
these runners are hollowed out and there
are openings to the hollow interior on
the tops and sides of the trunks air
will often funnel in through the top
opening and blow out through the side
openings creating a variety of tones the
leaves on the branches of these trees
grow in a curled funnel-like shape the
constant production of tones by the
runners fills the groves with a flowing
improvisational melody providing a
pleasant acoustic background for
visitors this constant stream of sound
is then funneled into the forest leaves
into the center of the spirals where the
air once again enters into the inner
workings of the runners wood nymphs and
scholars who have studied the groves
believe that this constant passing back
and forth of music between the trees is
the forest thinking to itself among
these there is a small following which
believes the forest is only asleep and
that the great wood beasts will one day
awake and rise out of
Gobert peak the unique hollowed-out
trunks of the escal burke forests
provide habitats for numerous small
animals including sizable populations of
burnt muscle and zoo true the forest is
also the only location in which the bulb
nut squirrels are found naturally this
vibrant ecosystem makes the forest
popular among amateur naturalists and
seasoned explorers alike fire mains
intensely proud animals fire mains roam
the shy new Plains in prides ranging
from 10 to 15 members closely resembling
a lion at bass fire mains are also named
for the Scarlet iridescent hairs that
ring the necks of both the male and
female and raced down the sides and
backs in horizontal stripes this fur is
highly prized as a material for clothing
though there are very strict laws placed
on fire main hunting however unlike the
lion fire Mane's possess two pairs of
antlers that rise regally from their
heads behind the ears like a stag and
race across the savanna on three pairs
of scaly reptilian legs fire Mane's love
the thrill of the chase while in pursuit
of prey often purposefully letting the
prey go
should they catch it too quickly while
some may say this game of catch and
release is cruel it is nonetheless a
fascinating spectacle to see as the fire
mains become a flaming blur on the
grassy fields
while not hunting they can be seen
racing each other and if approached with
caution and presented with respect other
beings such as wizards elves and even
dragons a lucky few have been blessed
with the fortune of even riding them a
magician I knew named Jiang told me his
account of riding a fire main he
befriended years ago he said at first he
held on for dear life as the Beast took
off but as he gained his hold it was an
exhilarating and unforgettable
experience as he and the fire main raced
through the night sky they almost looked
like a comet flying along the ground
gyro gliders a type of newt light
creature native to the beaches and
cliffs of the southern scene gyro
gliders are unusual for amphibians
because they possess fully functional
wings or something close to them at
least these wings resemble long webbed
fins that can open and close like a fan
when the gyro glider contracts and
relaxes its muscles there are two pairs
stacked directly on top of another with
the bottom set slightly longer unlike
birds or bats that flap their wings up
and down the gyro glider spins its wings
in a circle the top set turning
clockwise and the bottom in Reverse
gyro gliders are thrill-seekers
particularly the males during the mating
season in summer they can be seen taking
like for risking leaps off the cliff
walls to the beach below performing a
multitude of spins and flips on the way
down to the beach below the closer they
come to the beach before pulling up to
safety the more attention they get from
potential mates females can also be seen
jumping though they prefer to glide and
loop as opposed to the males chaotic
flamboyant routine when not performing
daredevil jumps they spend most of their
time clinging to the beach cliffs or
within the many holes and cracks of the
rock these creatures come in a stunning
array of colors ranging from turquoise
and white to pink and gold to silver and
green it is common for gyro gliders to
mate with one that does not possess
their own color scheme this practice
continues to produce wide arrays of
different shades and color combinations
gyro blinders lay their eggs in
treacherous waters full of hidden rocks
and boulders there by discouraging
predators from making a meal their eggs
are round and numerous like a fishes and
coated with an adhesive that anchors the
eggs to the rocks the young hatch within
30 days and will spend the first few
weeks of their life in the water until
their wings develop afterwards they will
spin and loop up to the rest of the
colony ready to become the next
generation of daredevil jumpers
[Music]
hop serve uppers a charming and modely
entertaining species hop servers were
created by the flu elves about a hundred
years ago using an array of housework
and cooking spells the hop serve offers
goal to prepare and serve delicious food
wherever and whenever a banquet is held
the hop serve opera resembles a large
white egg with a single colored dot in
the center of their faces that
superficially looks like a simple I
usually blue or green when the hop serve
Opera is not preparing food this dot
will change color depending on how near
a meal that creature is preparing is to
completion when the circle turns red or
pink the food is ready to serve what
makes the hop survivors so intriguing is
that they prepare the food inside their
bodies with the help of the magic given
to them by the flu during their creation
when hop survivors have finished making
food they crack open to reveal the meal
inside which can range from steaming
piles of meat and delicious balls of
soups to beautifully arranged fruits and
desserts once the food is taken the hop
survivor closes again without any harm
and goes back to preparing food as
needed until a feast is done hop servers
move around on a single human-like foot
that is the same white as their egg body
if in the middle of making a meal and is
not uncommon to hear the hop serve Opera
present humming a soft cheery tune as
they open and close it is also not
uncommon to hear the sounds of jostling
metal coming from inside them as they
move to and fro it almost sounds like
hop servers carry a multitude of cooking
supplies and utensils inside them
however not even the flu elves know what
goes on inside a hop survivor's body
though given the deliciousness of the
end product the hop server's magic is a
treat for anyone who is invited to a flu
banquet or as a certified zoologist it's
my job to venture into any and all
regions in the fantastic lands to
discover new species one of the more
perilous journeys took me to the ku pre
iceland's a flat stretch of snow that is
deceptively deep
there are countless legends of a whole
world living below the snowfall tales of
things such as ice elves and ancient
monsters that have been hibernating for
centuries such legends are an enticing
incentive for people such as myself to
explore and although travel parties have
never discovered the being spoken of in
the fables we have discovered more than
20 new animal species hidden in the ice
from the shy and plump Lunars that
huddle in the hundreds to conserve body
heat to the snow Lance's that lie in
waiting to spear unfortunate prey with
their icicle tipped horns and in all
these travels we relied on the hardiness
and warmth of the Eeyore to make sure we
wouldn't freeze to death on our journeys
the Eeyore are a group of beasts that
have been domesticated by the Cupra
villagers for decades your are
incredibly docile at most grunting
softly when annoyed and perhaps kicking
a shower of snow at someone somehow I
think the sight of seeing someone
the wildered they are covered from head
to toe and snow amuses the beasts if one
does such an act others nearby will
rumble together in a chorus that sounds
almost like laughter ears walk on four
legs arranged like a cross that are as
thick as tree trunks with strong flat
feet that allow them to walk across the
deep snow without sinking their heads
are small relative to the rest of their
bodies and is
reminiscent of a turtle large folds of
fat that are surprisingly warm line the
ears back and store the necessary
sustenance for the animal in times when
food is scarce however the most
fascinating parts of the ear are the
large multiple fin like growths that
ring the sides of the fat vault made of
hollow bone at the base these fins are
transparent and shine and iridescent
white during the short times of sunlight
in the Cooper II isolates in just a few
hours of Sun these growths can absorb
and retain an astounding amount of heat
for the cold nights whenever we would
camp the Eeyore would spread these
growths like a fan the fins would glow
red with the warmth and calm of a
comforting fire and no matter the frigid
temperatures around us with the Eeyore
we would always sleep peacefully
George wax North Lakes have long been
used by the various diminutive races of
the fantastic lands for transport racing
and beasts of burden in at least one of
the pixie societies in the Midlands a
Pixies wealth can be determined by the
size and quality of their herd even the
largest Hjorth Wak that I have seen was
small enough to fit in my hand the
perfect proportion for most of their
masters in terms of their head and body
shape their appearance is similar to a
cross between a horse and an antelope
out of the head grows a pair of
relatively large curled branching
antlers each North wack possesses six
legs very similar to those of a cricket
which they use for leaping gorge walk
scum in a variety of vibrant colors
mostly pinkish red and green but blue
and gold varieties also exist though
these are more commonly reserved for
Knights and royalty one of the
historical accounts including Hjorth wax
that I find most interesting is the
Battle of Corps for several years a war
had been raging as the mavs --is--
sprites attempted to drive the invading
courage
out of their territories the wizard
gland granted the sprites a boon by
increasing their size so that they might
fight on equal footing with their
gnomish forces however during their
change the sprites Hjorth wax also
increased in size after over running the
gnomish forces on the field of battle
the sprites were able to use the
newfound leaping strength of their
Hjorth wax to reach the gnomes secluded
mountain stronghold
of coure forcing peace and bringing the
gnomes under their rule key referred
door shards approximately 200 years ago
in the second door of an empire of the
north king karthik the fourth
commissioned a massive Treasury to be
constructed within mount Kyra fur in
order to house the kingdom's supply of
gold on the southeastern face of the
mountain an enormous door to the
Treasury was placed in the cliff face
this door was enchanted to only
recognize and allow members of the royal
court into the treasury unfortunately
King Karthik and his builder had not
anticipated the battering rams and
catapults of the northern Giants while
the cure for door was shattered its many
fragments retained parts of its
enchantment each shard took on its own
personality and name the shards are
capable of projecting their thoughts
into the mind of their holder usually in
the form of images songs tales and
conversation the shards can also
communicate with each other if they are
in close enough proximity and to holders
which are close enough together and hold
a conversation of thoughts through their
shards
following the breaking of the door the
cure for shards were collected and
dispersed throughout the fantastic lands
in many places they were cut polished
and sold as exotic jewelry in other
places the shards were treasured for
their eccentric and curious
personalities and were used by artists
as muses of inspiration by myself
carried a cure for shard companion named
hafidh with me on a necklace for several
years the lightning struck Titan it is a
mercy to all of the fantastic lands that
the lightning struck Titan only awakens
with the passing of a mirage storm every
300 years in the southern jagged
mountains of kore the Beast resembles a
beetle or hermit crab with a dragon's
head covered in a Goliath pyramid of
stone and dirt that accumulates over its
300 years slumbers a huge crumbling
spiraling tower resides on its back
built by the same sorcerer whom the
storm that awakens the Beast is named
after them araf came to the fantastic
lands 2,000 years ago in a search to
build a place where he could practice
and perfect his art of weather spells
the jagged mountains proved ideal to him
with their isolation and formidable
appearance he began to construct his
tower at the plateau of the highest
mountain he could find it would take him
15 years to complete as soon as the
final brick was placed he began to call
forth a thunderstorm more powerful than
any the mountains had seen the Lightning
surged from the spire of a mirage tower
to the base and below each strike
stirring the Beast he had built his
tower upon with earth-shaking might the
Titan stretched its legs and rose a
thousand foot Goliath that bellowed as
the storm caused it pain while at the
same time restoring it to light the
lightning struck Titan began to move
once more eating huge chunks of Earth
and stone from the cliffs
with its tooth tamal and all the while
the storm raged above its back
following the titan as it lumbered
through the jagged mountains vomer off
himself perished as his tower collapsed
with each step the giant took the
Dragons sawed at once to try and stop
the Beast or at the very least impeded
but the titan was impervious to all
magic it was an ancient long-forgotten
creature a force of nature and it seemed
its rampage would destroy all of the
fantastic lands finally a group of mages
led by the sorceress named Talia arrived
they cast a spell that created the great
winds to drive the storm away from the
lightning struck titan and the beast
began to slow as the energy gained from
the storm disappeared it managed to
return to its resting place before
falling asleep once again and the lands
it raised fell silent Talia and her
group were hailed as heroes and they
turned their efforts to restoring the
damage done by the titan afterwards they
would guard the jagged mountains until
their deaths continuing to strengthen
the enchantment that kept vomer off
storm and the lightning struck titan
apart however the two are bound to meet
again
Vollmer off storm returns every three
hundred years from its banishment in the
howling sands to reawaken the beast
below the last time the titan awoke was
a hundred and eighty-seven years ago I
fear the day when we must again
prepare for the worst monoliths to
heaven
in the flat south eastern plains of
jinwu
a group of creatures live in a group
that grows by a mere one member at the
beginning of each year the monoliths
to heaven each a monolith is less flesh
and more stone made of obsidian they are
shaped like a rugged ellipse with a
singular large hole running through the
top portion like a downward staring eye
- spindly legs jut out and then fall to
the ground from the center of the
monolith legs that look like they would
never be able to support a creature of a
monoliths mass however the monoliths
deep magical ties with the Stars allow
them to stand for the long walk they
must undertake every new year monoliths
travel between two locations and two
locations only one is the site of a
meteor a crater that spans a thousand
feet wide the other is a tomb for G Aang
the magician the monoliths creator known
for his near eccentric obsession with
the Stars
jiaying frequently ventured to the shiny
planes with stargazing gear constantly
looking for what he claimed to be a
heavenly planet such a planet is vaguely
described in LJ new texts but only as
folk tip a legend however until his
dying breath G Aang believed the
heavenly planet to be more than just a
myth and so created the monoliths to
carry out his work when he himself could
no longer achieve his dream until the
week before the new year the monoliths
remained buried in a ring around G
Yang's tomb during this time the holes
in their bodies create various patterns
as the Sun rises and sets
once Eve falls on the week before the
new year the monoliths rise from their
slumber one by one and it is during this
time that one can see G Aang's
determination to ascend to the heavenly
planet
the tallest current monolith towers a
staggering 600 feet in the air each
following Monell at this 50 feet shorter
for a total of a dozen as the sky
darkens the monoliths begin a slow
50-mile walk to the crater site with
only starlight to guide them as they
walk in descending order they almost
look like the stairs of a Giant's Castle
on the dawn of the new year when they
have gathered in the center of the
crater the birth of a new monolith
begins still in their descending order
the light of the new Sun shines through
the halls of the monoliths to the ground
illuminating the spot where a new member
will rise from the ground born from the
fragments of the meteor that struck the
fantastic lands 2,000 years ago this new
member will become the new tallest
monolith the next stepping stone to G
Yang's fabled world once the new
monolith takes its place at the front of
the line the stone giants begin their
walk back to the grave of their master
where they bury themselves once again
until the next year note people in all
my travels through this fantastic world
the note people that live in the eastern
plains of Darius stand out as the most
unique and wondrous creatures living
music created 200 years ago when a
sorceress called Eliana sought to create
enchanted musical instruments capable of
producing the most beautiful sounds ever
heard instead she created the note
people as the spell intended to make a
symphony progressed the ink and notes
inscribed on the enchantment papers
quite literally flew off the parchment
and began to coalesce in a swirl of
sound and symbols they took on the shape
of their creator creating the first note
woman the Liana would grow old but the
note woman continued to stay with her
forever playing music when her Creator
desired it Eliana would create dozens
more of its kind before she died
an age of a hundred and fifty two years
the note people themselves would carry
her body away into the plains they now
inhabit the sound that the harp reads
and grasses make while blowing in the
wind
greatly appeals to their kind the note
people today are just as if not more
talented in magic and music they delight
in having visitors to entertain
oftentimes taking whoever comes across
them by hand and bringing them to its
friends
it is rather odd to be touched by a note
man the notes and lines that make up
their bodies are nearly flat working
together to make a three-dimensional
form yet they feel cool almost like thin
delicate paper they can shift their
bodies into whatever form they please
i've even seen note people exchange and
mix their music to produce sounds that
they could not accomplish on their own
note people have a special affinity for
starlight moths that provide lights to
the plains in the night being inky black
themselves note people will often try to
capture the starlight moths within their
bodies to make them visible for nightly
performances it was during such a
performance that I was able to witness
the note people for the first time on a
warm summer evening with the harp reeds
and grass humming softly along with the
music of the note people
it will be an experience I will never
forget ocean sippers it was while
visiting to the fishing ports of the
South that I learned of the wondrous
ocean sippers the suntan fishermen I
spoke to had encountered them almost
daily on their voyages and had collected
several objects of study among these
were several sketches pellets and even
an injured specimen that they had taken
on board at first glance a sipper looks
to be some kind of large iridescent bird
similar in appearance to a pigeon on
closer inspection however it becomes
apparent that in place of feathers the
creature is covered in a material with a
blend of traits of feathers and scales
like scales pieces of the material have
the texture of the scales of a fish and
are firmly connected to the body
however the shape of the pieces are more
similar to the feathers one would see in
any other sea bird and even resembled
down in some places zippers are capable
of breathing in both air and fresh water
and spend most of their time as part of
a flock in a large bubble of water which
drifts high above the iridescent sea
this bubble follows the course of
schools of small fish or prawns
at night the sippers die from their
bubble to the surface of the ocean where
they skim off and swallow a layer of
prey and sea water before returning to
their abode the combination of sea water
and food is then processed in their guts
until they regurgitate it as fresh water
and a small pellet composed of salt and
the remains of their prey
the water is added to their bubble to
compensate for evaporation while the
pellet is tossed down toward the ocean
below fishermen will often collect the
pellets either for their supply of
iridescent salt or in order to sell them
to tourists at the ports Polly Danes
among some of the most curious forms of
life in the fantastic lands are the
Polly Danes Polly Danes can be found all
throughout the world though they are
especially concentrated in western
cities and in places populated by large
groups of other races in their true
forms Polly Danes are roughly the same
size and shape as a human but they have
a second set of arms and a blank smooth
Dover face their bodies appeared to be
composed of various colors of clay in a
marbled pattern
Polly Danes are able to stretch and mold
and reshape their bodies at will and can
take on the properties of other
materials such as stone or flesh on
occasion Polly Danes will take the form
of an inanimate object though more often
they emulate another race before
mingling with other members of that race
at other times Polly Danes will take
whimsical are nonsensical forms for
their own or others amusement Polly
Danes are capable of reproduction in two
ways the first is through reproduction
with another individual Polly Dane or
otherwise and the second is through a
single Polly Dane individual dividing
into two distinct individuals in
addition Polly Danes bodies do not age
naturally and damage from physical
attacks against them is not lasting in
most cases a species which can multiply
without aging or being killed would
overtake and crowd their environment but
such is not the case for Polly Danes
though their bodies are long-lived and
in pervious their spirits will still age
and often pass on after a hundred years
or so
once their spirit is gone the Polly
Danes body will revert to its natural
clay form and will begin to dry dying
completely once it's fully dry
if a sapient individual encounters the
body before it's fully dry they can will
their consciousness into the empty husk
leaving their older form behind and
beginning their life anew as a Polly de
coeur blurs there is still much debate
over the nature of core blurs some
profess that they are collections of
very communal spirits others claim that
they are merely a novel of variation of
atuh might or blurs are often found in
the various woods of the northern cliffs
from a distance they appear as
shimmering patterns along the surface of
trees however should a traveler pass by
them the core blur will remove
themselves from the tree and appear in
front of the traveler as a swirling
pillar of light the core blur will
refuse to move out of the way until the
traveler has beaten them in some
challenge usually in the form of a
riddle or a game of chance
should the traveller win this challenge
the core blur will allow them to travel
on show the traveler fail however the
core blur will enter through the
travelers mouth and take command of the
traveler the core blur possessed
individual will then make their way back
to a village town or city where they
will take part in feasts festivals and
other merriment individuals who are
possessed by core blurs can be
identified by both their eccentric and
celebratory behavior and by the swirls
of light that can be seen in their eyes
core blurs may leave of their own accord
after celebrating for a few days but
they can also be coaxed out by placing
meats cheeses tarts and spiced wine just
out of reach
of a possessed individual individuals
who have been possessed by a core blur
are often no worse for the wear
aside from exhaustion and embarrassing
stories accumulated from their excessive
partying
nearly 40 years ago one possessed
individual led a large group of poor
blurs to the northern village of oaken
it took a full two weeks for the dragons
to get word of the news and sort out the
affected citizenry
however glad the citizens were to have
their wits back about them they did miss
the merriment that the queers had
brought them this paired with the fact
that the queer blurs meant no ill will
and had only been searching for a place
to escape the cold of the woods led to
the creation of a yearly holiday anokhin
and the surrounding villages where in
the villages are open for a full week to
the queer blurs so that they and the
villagers may celebrate to their heart's
content Ruia blarts
partially named for the distinct deep
bubbling they periodically make to
sustain their levels of buoyancy Reeb
warts are immense jellyfish-like
creatures used by merfolk throughout the
fantastic lands in constructing their
undersea homes anywhere from 1 to 500
feet in diameter at the Bell Roo you
arts may look like jellyfish apart from
the large simple almost horse-like head
that matches the same transparency and
jelly-like state as the rest of the body
but unlike jellyfish their tentacles do
not contain any poisons and are actually
more or less vestigial growths Rueb
warts are primarily filter feeders and
are to some extent photosynthetic the
Bell is an enormous air sac that keeps
the Ruby of Lourdes suspended in the
water air is taken in and released
through a circle of small tubes near the
base of the Bell at night they glow
through a soft cycle translucent
turquoise pink and green merfolk are
well known for their pickiness when it
comes to decorations always wanting to
find a balance between structure and
aesthetics to complement the calming
iridescent of the reuploads back the
merfolk takes such items as discarded
abalone shells glass corals and
Perle sponges as building materials
constructing beautifully elegant towers
as they continue to build and live on
the real arts backs the rural arts get
to eat any scraps that float off the MER
cities depending on the clan and
location ruia blurts cities can have
anywhere from 10 to over 40 of the
gentle giants floating together with the
right spells land dwellers can journey
with the merfolk under the sea and enter
an almost otherworldly realm of soft
rainbow light as fish whales and merfolk
alike swim around and within the ruie of
llort metropolis son Steelers years
after the close brush with the bungles I
would make three more ventures into the
Blackrock forest however on the forth
journey I was in search of one creature
in particular the fabled beings known as
son stealers said to be tall as the
trees themselves and black and cold as a
starless night heavens no why I would
actually want to intentionally go
looking for them the Dragons once again
sent help with me this time with a young
sapphire dragon wing named teria and a
wise steel back named Joe Noddy
before leaving Garen ran up to us with a
last-minute gift as well a potion that
would turn us dark as the Blackrock
forest so that the creatures hiding
within could not spy us as we invaded
their home
Darren himself would not dare accompany
us again I do not think any less of him
for doing so the trip to the Blackrock
forest felt different this time colder
like the creatures expected our return
and were gleefully waiting to strike as
soon as we stepped foot into their lair
I suspected it was just nerves though as
we passed through the rugged Lane I
could not help but begin to have second
thoughts about coming back as the first
black rock shrubs came into view and the
new moon cast darkness onto the ground
tyria jar Noddy and I too
alt Gardens gift and each took a drink
from the model it was like having a
barrel of water from the glaciers of the
ridge forced down your throat but when
the chills passed we could tell Garen's
work had been done we were all still
able to see each other but each of us
looked like a reflection in slowly
rippling water a camouflage to shield us
from whatever lurked in the trees we
studied our minds and once again went
into the ashen trail son stealers were
said to live deep within the Black Rock
trees where the air itself feels like
floating pitch and the slightest sound
echoes like the crackling of a thousand
bones we journeyed for what I think was
two days all the while the ashen trail
grew less and less pronounced and the
darkness became overwhelming more than
once jar knotty suggested we concede and
turned back but I was stubborn and tario
was eager for adventure we pushed on on
the fifth day jar Noddy spotted
something a patch of darkness even more
ominous than the surrounding black a
darkness that rippled and seemed to
ripple in churn I knew at once we had
found his son Steeler Grove it was well
off the ashen trail though we knew that
we must step off the path teria was the
first to go forward I am slightly
ashamed to say I was the third the chill
grew frigid as we came closer the
silence all-consuming but we still
pressed on after moving a mere twenty
paces we were soaked with sweat near
collapse but we made it and we waited to
gaze upon a son Steeler with a mix of
terror and excitement none came we
waited for hours and the creatures never
appeared it was maddening time slipped
away
on the third day yar Noddy finally told
us to go back and with hearts heavy
provisions low and mines fogging we
relented
and as we neared the clearing back into
the rugged paths the son stealers
appeared the old scriptures were true
tall as the trees like a shroud woven
from a black sky a smooth white
depression for a face to black
expressionless eyes that looked on us
like a child about to curiously crush an
insect an ebony crown that floated above
their heads with long slender points and
above the crown an orb that looked like
a star an orb that made me realize why
the son Steelers were so aptly named the
Crown's seemed to suck light from the
circle the globe changing from white to
gray to black as it reached the Crown's
base but it didn't end with the stars
within their crowns what little light
that snuck through the trees was dragged
to them as well the black leaves
withering as they lost what little Sun
they can live from the creatures living
within them fleeing or falling dead at
the creatures feet Turia died the son
stealers enveloped her in their cloaks
and when they moved away she was nothing
more than a weathered skin they parted
as if telling jar naughty and I to leave
as if we had paid the price for their
mercy with one life we stumbled away and
when I looked back they were gone the
ashen trail was overrun with new
Blackrock plants as if it had never
existed that was my fourth and final
visit to the forest without the ashen
trail the Dragons themselves have
refused to go back Trimble wise
Trimble wise are among the most numerous
creatures in all of fantasy and with
good reason they are able to thrive in
nearly any environment where there is
food outwardly Trimble wise begin their
life with an appearance similar to that
of a mouse though without a noticeable
tail and much more root unde they have
white coats of fur and ruby eyes as a
Trimble Weiss carries on through its
life its development is shaped by the
food it eats the type of food that the
Trimble y Sates will cause changes in
its size shape coat and even
occasionally the limbs it possesses just
as the type of food that the Trimble
wise eats affects its outward appearance
the quality of the food it eats changes
its disposition high quality food causes
the Trimble eyes to become tame and
domestic while garbage causes it to
become vicious and dangerous for this
reason families will often forego eating
the choice portions of their meal in
order to appease and train the Trimble
wise which may be living in their house
while paying a visit to the court of
Florent I was treated by my host to a
pair of curiosities the count was in
possession of two very unique specimens
of Trimble ones one of which had only
ever been fed on gulp and a second which
had only ever been fed on rose petals
the first had grown in size an
appreciable amount and had a sleek coat
of golden coloration and it was much
thinner on the front than in the back
giving in a kind of egg shape the second
did not seem to have grown much if
anything in a trunk however its coat had
been replaced by brilliant layers of red
feathers and it had a thick tail similar
to a dragon's later that night the count
and I feasted on what I was informed was
a Trimble wise which had been raised on
a diet of beef pork and veal
I found the meal quite to my liking
[Music]
unison the unison is one of the most
elusive creatures in all of fantasy I
fear I a little to report on it as in
spite of all the evidence of its
existence no man
dragon elf or dwarf has made clear
observation of it there is even still
doubt as to whether the unison is a
single beasts or an entire species these
unknown elements only add to its injury
which is why I have included it in this
collection the Utzon moves at an
extremely rapid pace which is the main
reason it has been able to evade
observation or capture for all these
years
it seems to know instinctively where its
hunters are looking constantly moving
out of sight or hiding behind secluded
cover it never seems to leave behind any
hair or scent only its footprints the
trail of prints that the unit and leaves
are highly unusual and are the only
aspect of the creatures existence which
can be readily observed the prints are
composed of a single large circle about
the size of a deers hoof with two
smaller circles on the sides of it and
two other circles behind it once made a
large jet of steam will rise out of each
print mixing in with the morning mists
that are present when the Yuson is most
active interestingly the arrangements of
the prints may change over time and have
indicated at different times that the
Unison has anywhere between 1 and 12
lengths
then thrill the Vince roll are a group
of creatures then inhabit the jagged
Valley about three corners of the way
along the trail to the Black Rock forest
also known as the winged bungle the
ventral does indeed resemble the
towering mana pedes in the Blackrock
forest with its round hairy head and
mouth full of needle-like teeth but they
are in fact entirely different species
ventral do not possess faint instead
using their large clawed bat-like wings
for both flying and climbing through the
cliffs of the jagged Valley as it glides
a long tail lined evenly with three to
six balls of fur similar to its head
trails behind producing a soft whistling
sound as the wind passes through the
hairs though ventral are not above
devouring travelers or other animals
unfortunate enough to cross them they
are actually predominantly fruit eaters
specifically they eat the fruit of the
maroon trees that are strong enough to
grow on the sides of the cliff faces the
fruit of these trees looks exactly like
the head of the ventral round and
covered in fibers and cell residents of
the fantastic lands have taken to
calling it ventral fruit
while not particularly tasty to most in
the fantastic lands to the ventral these
fruits play an invaluable role in their
reproduction a female ventral will swoop
and snatch a number of fruits off a tree
while pregnant and puncture a single
hole in the fruits hard outer shell from
there it regurgitates an infant ventral
no bigger than the tip of a finger into
the soft innards of the fruit before
flying off the fruit both serves as
protection and the food for the juvenile
ventral until it is strong enough to
break free up until recently people
thought this similar look between the
ventral and the ventral fruits were just
a coincidence though now it seems the
fruits play a larger role in developing
Vin's roles than previously thought
while exploring the jagged valley the
adventurer gaol beyond was attacked by a
pregnant ventura and only escaped by
throwing his pack of goo u melons behind
him which the ventral immediately took
and deposited eggs inside of before
flying off gal beyond intrigued as to
why the ventral birthed its young in a
non-native fruit stuck close to the
gooey melons until the ventral hatched
to his and many other zoologists when he
brought the ventral backs shock the
creature sported the same bright pink
and green coloration as the gooey
Ameland along with tough spikes lining
their bodies instead of the usual hairs
after this discovery a brief boom in
experimental ventral breeding occurred
with successful births and fruits such
as the coconut pumpkin and Daraa Daraa
cones however people soon realized that
these ventral suffered from terrible
sicknesses as they mature and died
painfully shortly after nowadays to
prevent the exploitation of exotic
hybrids as well as fear of damaging the
natural breeding process experimental
breeding of Ventura 'ls is illegal and
there are several penalties inflicted on
anyone who tries to entice of intro to
birth young in anything other than the
ventral fruit
Watchers of the waning moon once in a
while I will come across a creature that
I feel I will never truly be able to
understand the watchers of the waning
moon are such a group shrouded in
mystery and practitioners in a strange
and surreal act that even the Dragons
cannot explain Watchers live in the
brush of the eastern plains only
appearing at night they have the head
and front body of a white stag with thin
fine antlers adorned with moon Lily buds
some say the antlers are not horns at
all but actual moon lily plants that
have sprouted and rooted into their
heads however due to the Watchers
curious nature no one has been able to
prove one theory or another the back end
of the animal is the tail of a serpent
long smooth scaled and pearly the tip of
the tail ends in a single large moon
Lily which like the flowers on the
Watchers antlers will remain a bud until
the moment of the Watchers death
these creatures are intensely shy
fleeing and vanishing in a cloud of mist
should someone spot them the only time
they show themselves is during the time
of the waning crescent of the first moon
during which dozens of Watchers will
gather at the plains thicket and
undertake a ritual unlike any other when
the waning crescent of the first moon is
highest in the sky one watcher from
those present will step forward and
begin to climb and snake their way up
the trees until it rests on top of the
leaves those below begin to rock and
circle and rhythm their movement along
the ground creating strange and
perplexing patterns all the while they
hum a low base like chorus as the
patterns increase in number the moon
lilies on the tail and antlers of the
watchers atop the trees will begin to
open once the lilies are fully bloomed
the watcher will let out a long
drawn-out cry before pushing off and
jumping high into the air the lilies
will begin to release wisps of pollen
and The Watcher will inexplicably
continue to rise like a flying snake for
hundreds of feet continuing to ascend
towards
the moon however as soon as the lilies
pollen is spent the watcher will cease
to rise and plummet to the ground upon
impact the broken body of the animal
will dissolve into a mist which rises
and dissipates into the night sky all
other Watchers will appear to sigh and
faint clouding the thicket with the same
mist until they all disappear afterwards
the only evidence of them ever being
present are the strange patterns they
drew upon the ground when I asked the
librarian dragons / ayan Luth onna about
the Watchers strange practice they told
me they could only guess there are
several scripts that provide a theory to
the Watchers behaviour some say that the
Watchers believe the waning crescent is
one of their own an individual that has
attained transcendence in the heavens
and that the creatures on this earth are
attempting to join it indeed the moon
crescent resembles an arching snake
other scripts believe the opposite that
the creatures see the moon as a watcher
trapped in the sky and that in jumping
they are attempting to grab it and bring
it back down either way it is a
fascinating but thoroughly enigmatic
insight into the watcher of the waning
moon whatever the reason they show no
signs of stopping their ceremony I
wonder if they will ever realize that
the moon cannot be caught Tsar Goths the
Vohland dwarfs that lived within the
steam caverns just miles from the ridge
are known for their unmatched talent in
metalworking and gem cutting indeed the
geothermal caves which they have made
their home in are abundant with rare
metals and gemstones and accounts for
nearly 40% of all jewelry traded through
the fantastic lands any piece made by
the villain is a fine treasure to
possess during their mining in the steam
caverns the Voland began to notice that
carts of gems would return to the
surface with fewer stones than
originally loaded though at first
confused they quickly found a creature
mixed in with their gems that was
indistinguishable from the stones except
when it was feeding
the Czar Garth's czar Garth's start
their lives looking similar to stones
such as geodes or agates with their
outer skin covered in a sturdy shell
that looks exactly like rock within this
shell is a mismatch of tissue and organs
Tsar Goths can spout small red tentacles
for locomotion as they move a roll of
microscopic teeth scraped minerals and
gather organic matter from the steam
caverns floors and walls as they grow
older the Tsar Goths begin to abandon
feeding on organic matter and turn
solely to stones for food much to the
voulons dismay gemstones were the Czar
Goths favored treat after ingesting the
crystals Tsar Garth's incorporate them
into their outer shell where they grow
along with the rest of the creature as
if they were part of the body itself the
older azar Garth grows the deeper it
tunnels into the earth to find more
bountiful feasts of jewels eventually
they resembled giant slug like creatures
covered in countless crystal growths
dozens of small stubby legs carry the
Czar cars body as its skidders along the
ground although it first considered a
destructive pest to the gem trade the
Voland have since been domesticating
czar Garth's as both a pet and a
business helper as it turns out Tsar
Goths shed crystals that grow too large
these discarded gems are collected and
sold as they are or further cut into an
array of jewellery different Tsar Goths
have different preferences for what
jewels they ingest so the Bullen are
sure to keep scouting for further
varieties of Tsar Garth subspecies
during my last visit I saw magnificent
specimens of ruby opal and even diamond
czar Garth's in ruling care the good
dwarf layer gave me a beautiful fire
opal that had fallen off one of the
creatures which I now carry in my travel
bag wherever I go
the Yan yaar and the n URIs there is a
forested ring of islands east of the
fantastic lands that has been left
largely uncharted due to a species even
the Dragons shudder to hear mentioned
the Y and Y are the Yan Yan spread cold
and lifelessness or ever they walk
blanching everything around them as they
continuously SAP vitality anything
living or inanimate that comes too close
to the Yan yar will collapse grade and
cold in a matter of seconds such
behavior has caused the trees the earth
and even the surrounding sea of their
home to turn gray as dust and so the Yan
yars home is aptly known as the
monochrome islands physically the annual
are tall and lean like the elves though
they do not wear garments and like any
parts to identify gender if they so have
them their skin is the same gray as
everything they touch and their hands
and feet both have long nail lists
digits that constantly grip an ungroup
the chilling fluidity however the most
distinctive and chilling part of the Yan
yar are their faces a bulbous smooth
head far too large for a body of their
thinness with squinted grey eyes that
appear disturbingly human while normally
featureless apart from the eyes the an
yars head will split vertically into
thirds to reveal two separate jaws with
even needle-like teeth during this time
no one can see that the Yan yars eyes
are more akin to a tongue a sensory
organ attached to a fleshy stalk that
runs all the way down its throat it is
believed that the yang yar are blind and
rely on these eyes to smell their
surroundings like a serpent tasting the
air
the first Yan Yan are ever seen washed
ashore on the beaches of the fantastic
lands sixty years ago and it was from
this corpses autopsy that most of the
information about this species was
attained it was easy to see where it had
come from even in death the an yars
corpse left a trail of
ray in the ocean waves though said trail
was lost after the Dragons pursued it
for dozens of miles offshore it would
take another 20 years to find the
monochrome islands yet only six months
for the Dragon Council to declare the
area off-limits to all most of the
fantastic lands inhabitants simply
believed the Yan yar were too dangerous
to go near and left it at that
I however know the deeper meaning behind
the monochrome island being sealed for
the world in a different time I would
have probably been imprisoned maybe even
banished from the fantastic lands
however now that my home is all but
abandoned I leave this information to
whomever may stumble upon it the Yan er
corpse we recovered was mutilated with
huge circular punctures throughout the
body strangely the wound had no exposed
flesh instead a black empty void filled
the gap when the poor dragon dr. Herod
astride to examine the wounds the void
turned his flesh to pure black he looked
like a living shadow in his final
moments then with a cry Herod is faded
out of existence when the dragons
finally discovered the monochrome
islands they found their explanation to
the darkness seen on the first yawn
yawns body beneath the dark waters of
the Yan yars home lays the end Eurus an
even more terrifying creature than the
beings above from what the Dragons
observed the an Eurus appeared to be
worshipped as a God by the Yan Yan the
annual will cast themselves off sheer
cliffs of the island to the sea below
where shadowy tentacles rise in the
thousands to spear the bodies and drag
them below it is unknown how large the
end yours is though its limbs alone are
long enough to effortlessly scale the
2,000 foot cliffs of the Yan yars home
and been some the touch of the end Eurus
appears to have the same graying effect
as the yan yards touch but on a much
more powerful scale capable of turning
things to blackness
and then nothing as seen with Herod Asst
the touch of the end URIs persists long
after initial contact this similarity
has driven me to make a hypothesis about
the beings relationship perhaps the end
URIs gave the an yar some of its power
years and years ago in return for their
servitude the dozens of islands
surrounding the Yan yars home shows
signs of ancient ruins could the Yang
yar have conquered these neighboring
lands and brought them to their master
when it seems like a plausible
explanation though since there has been
no life other than the Y and Y are the
enuresis since resorted to devouring its
servants the once much beneficial
relationship has become grimly one-sided
Zira LASP in a fitting but bitter sense
the Cyril ASPs will be the last entry in
this storybook as they were the last
creatures of the fantastic lands at the
end of the war and the first to die out
in the new beginning although their
bodies resembled that of a swan their
skin was more attuned to that of the
pearl crested dolphins that once swam
the iridescent seas to the south their
eyes were the deepest of blue their
wings forever softly shining like fluid
ivory their mouths a smooth
toothless bill that curved ever so
slightly upward they were capable of
taking a human form as well resembling
angels and on all those they passed as
beautiful as they were intelligent
Nazira last for a vain and conceited
race of creatures who forever squabbled
with the Dragons over whose wisdom and
looks were superior and so were disliked
by a great number of the fantastic lands
inhabitants for whom the dragons were
born leaders and advisors as a result
the zero LASP
secluded themselves from all other
beings for nearly a millennia
constructing a citadel of their own to
live apart from those they deemed
inferior they ignored all pleas for help
in times of calamity
and rejected all offerings of friendship
it was not until the third awakening of
the lightning struck titan that the seer
alas were seen again VAM roth storm
returned with terrifying ferocity and
the titan rose with its strength
multiplied tenfold
half of the magician's council perished
in the ensuing fight with the beasts
along with nearly a hundred dragons a
thousand Birds and a thousand more
spirits and still the Zira LASP
refused to act and so the maker himself
came to the Zira LASP his face dark with
fury his eyes normally full of
compassion brimming with icy rage he
spurned their race accused them of being
petty cowards who watched as their world
burned around them for their vanity he
cursed their Citadel enchanted it so
that no Azurill ASP could ever set foot
in it again then covered it in the ashes
of those killed by the titan as a
reminder of the suffering the Cyril ASP
could have helped prevent overcome with
despair of what they had lost and what
they could have had
Azurill ASP vowed to never turn their
backs on the rest of the fantastic lands
again and charged into the center of the
Titans path side by side with the
Dragons they once despised and the
master they adored the Cyril ASP
beat back the Beast to its Mountain once
again the titan fell back into its
slumber but the grief and devastation
brought about lingered for decades to
come
the Cyril ASP worked with renewed fervor
in rebuilding to make up for all the
time they had shut themselves away they
became the chief architects of the
fantastic lands and filled this world
with their incredible and intricate
handcraft
this lasted for another thousand years
and life prospered and less than three
decades ago the Great War began and all
the zero last pad or ever would create
was destroyed and the calamity that
followed
once again the maker came but this time
his eyes held only grief as he was
forced to smite those who had fanned the
flames of destruction Azurill ASP
desperately tried to bring back peace
but to no avail
and so they fell into despair when the
last buildings finally crumbled
Azura last but turned black from the ash
and smoke their blue eyes turned bloody
red from grief as the surviving others
filed out of the fantastic lands the
zero LASP stayed behind silent as the
stones of their cities and within these
ruins they remain turned to stone
as the Sun sets for the final time and
the world turned cold
so there you have it folks
the last memories that we have of SCP
1762 and the land that they come from
wait what what is what is this is this
this the containment breach tell me I'm
not the only one seeing this what does
this mean that does this mean they're
back you all seen the box materialized
right that wasn't there whenever we came
in here it wasn't here whenever I was
eating my lunch I know that I swear if
this is taka naka playing a joke he is
dead
but he's not playing a joke that means
I'm dead wait a minute they just dropped
a note let me get that oh man this note
it says you didn't forget us
I guess whenever I read the book the
imagination triggered something you know
my lectures never really end with a
moral lesson but because of all this
what the Dragons have done and for the
first time in a year I have ended a
lecture with more people than I started
with
let's have a moral conclusion shall we
and that moral conclusion is this never
forget your loved ones keep them alive
with your memories and your stories and
your thoughts because if you do that and
then they're never truly gone thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
so before I thank my patrons I have to
thank SCP containment breach unity with
like these guys support this video would
not have turned out anywhere near as
good as I wanted it to turn out
especially Corvis be who put so much
effort into the musical score of this
video without Corvis babe this video
would not have signed that anywhere near
as good so I feel like I have to have a
specific shout out to Corvis in this
video I really hope you enjoyed this
video because it's the most fun I've had
creating a video in months the
containment breach unity team are true
professionals and we're a joy to work
with and I really want to do it again
so leave a comment down below if you
would like us to collaborate on a future
SCP because I really want to make this
happen if I worried I would go and
download SCP containment breach unity
and give it a try all links will be in
the description visit www.azpbs.org
would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert GM's sabah
chris all pablo ice 917 Caleb Chaffins
Karim El ash Mui
Justin de-rocker Imam Thomas Morin
Curie kuma white crew and jayvo jack
crystal spice my archive curator Nick
Kang modding and the wanderer thank you
all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgin thank you
you